Speaker 1: Let's see where we want to go next.
Oh, I don't know.
What about maybe Dave from Kansas City?
Dave, you're on the air.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: All righty, then.
First time caller.
I'm going to be as brief as I can.
It is kind of a loaded question.
Basically, my politics lean the same as you.
So there's no head to head here, if you will.
But I've not been keeping the best update
on the situation.
This is regarding the Supreme Court leak.
Okay.
Basically, you said something recently that
kind of made me raise an eyebrow and I've
seen other people do it as well.
So here we go.
Initially, it was stated by those on the right
that the left wing person did it to try to
pressure change from the leaked opinion.
Yep.
But later I heard that the right the rhetoric
changed to the likely a person on the right
putting pressure on the judges to keep their
vote.
The reason this raised an eyebrow for me was
because, you know, if you assume the least
amount of information out of all these using
Occam's Razor, these are the same amount of
assumptions.
What am I missing from the quote unquote likely?
Yeah, nature.
Speaker 1: That's a great question.
So basically, in terms of plausibility, when
it comes to the Supreme Court leak, you can
argue if you know nothing and you all you
have is motive.
You could say, well, a left winger would have
motive to leak it, to try to pressure the
justices who were going to vote to overturn
Roe v Wade, to change their mind from motive.
You could also say a right winger might have
leaked it in order to try to pressure the
justices planning to overturn Roe v Wade to
stick with that decision if they suspect that
maybe they were going to change.
So that you're absolutely right, we don't
have more information one way or the other.
We have gotten reports from longtime Supreme
Court reporters, including one from NPR, whose
name I don't remember offhand, who said, based
on everyone she's talked to, the consensus
within the court is that it was more likely
a right winger.
So that's that's the only difference maker.
You're correct that we have almost the same
thing on both sides.
Other than a couple of reports from long time
Supreme Court reporters who say the feeling
is it was more likely a right winger, we don't
know at this point.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Yeah, it was just something that kind of.
I didn't hear that last part.
Yeah, I think maybe now that I'm thinking
about it, I just couldn't find it going through.
I only have so much time to go through all
the videos.
But yeah.
Speaker 1: We link to the source in the story
I did about it.
We link to the NPR source.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Sounds good.
I'll check that up.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
We are going to take more calls in a moment.
I'm just going to take a very quick break
and then we'll be right back.
Just hold on and then we'll get to more people.
Let's go back to discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord and speak to some more people.
We use what's called the waiting lobby when
we take calls.
Why don't we speak to.
There's really a lot of people today who want
to chat, but we want to try to get to some
a wide representation.
Let's go to Brenda from Minnesota.
Brenda, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hello, David.
This is Brenda from Minnesota.
How are you doing today?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 4: I called specifically because I
don't know if you're familiar with Telltale.
Who is on has he has a several web YouTube
channels called Telltale Telltale Atheist
and stuff.
And he published a video recently that gives
specific instructions to women on how to get
an abortion.
Specifically for women who happen to be in
a state which may, you know, prevent prevent
them getting an abortion.
Specific instructions on exactly who who to
email and how to how to get abortion pills.
And it is.
Speaker 1: He.
Okay.
Hold on.
Brenda, I've got to interrupt you.
So this is a bit precarious only because I
don't know who this person is.
I don't know what their credentials are.
I'm not up to speed on the legality of, quote,
getting abortion pills and all of the different
legal infrastructure.
I just want to be really careful about what
we put out here, because I don't want to overstep
or create a problem of any kind for anyone,
including myself.
So I don't know.
I mean, listen, it's great that there are
resources out there for people, but let's
maybe ease up a little on the specifics here,
if we can.
Speaker 4: Okay.
So it is legal because you.
Speaker 1: Which part is legal?
Speaker 4: It is legal to receive abortion
pills through the mail.
This was a very recent thing.
Speaker 1: But now correct me if I'm wrong,
but isn't it that's legal in states where
it is already legal to obtain them?
Right.
I mean, that so so based on the existing legal
infrastructure, getting them through the mail
is okay.
Speaker 4: My understanding it's legal everywhere
in the United States.
Speaker 1: Okay.
See, that wasn't my understanding.
So.
Are you a lawyer by chance?
Speaker 4: No, I'm a nobody.
Speaker 1: I'm not either.
Just let's just.
Let's just be careful.
But so you you want people to look up Telltale,
is that right?
Speaker 4: I posted a link in the chat here.
He has a video.
And if you talk to him, you know, maybe your
concerns would be addressed more.
He'd be a good guest.
But also this information.
I think it'd be good to amplify this this
information.
It's if you if you hosted it, he has said
that he will not you know, he is not copyright
it or do any damn strikes.
But if you talk to him, maybe if you talk
to him more, he can be more specific on the
legalities.
Speaker 1: Good.
Okay, that sounds good.
Thank you, Brenda.
Speaker 4: Yeah, you're welcome.
Speaker 1: All right, there.
There is Brenda from Minnesota.
We just we don't want to do anything wrong
on the show.
You know, that's the that's the priority.
We want to be we want to be very careful